business about the impact of the coroner
virus outbreak on Monday so the doubt
wipe out year-to-date gains yet Bitcoin
is around 30 percent so far this year
far more over the last 12 months so is
it a safe haven in stormy markets or
something else entirely Morgan Creek
digital assets co-founder and partner
and flee popular node joins us now great
to have you with us so thanks so much
for having me here make two observations
about their corner virus outbreak not
that we want to take away from the
tragedy that it represents but the first
thing was mining because a lot of that
happens in China yep thoughts their big
thing is a lot of manufacturing plants
are being shut down and so those
companies are losing revenue but when it
comes to mining computers are doing most
of the work it takes very few humans so
mining is not impacted and it's also
very decentralized across the globe and
so if you get kind of a virus outbreak
in one geographic area this is necessary
to affect the mining hash rate nearly as
much and so I don't think that mining is
really susceptible to the same things
that like a traditional manufacturing
company is okay we're going to come back
to that I promise you but we'll move